cinco personas fueron capturadas por la
policía salvadoreña acusada de ser
responsable de la tragedia ocurrida en
un partido de fútbol el pasado 20 de
mayo en la que fallecieron 12 personas
tras una estampida de aficionados de la
alianza uno de los equipos más
reconocidos de la primera división el
suceso ocurrió en el partido de cuartos
de final entre los equipos Alianza y
Fast en el estadio Cuscatlán de la
capital salvadoreña entre los detenidos
se encuentran el presidente la gerente
financiera y el gerente de seguridad de
la alianza el gerente general de la
empresa que administra el estadio y el
encargado de las llaves del recinto
deportivo la fiscalía publicó en su
cuenta de Twitter que los capturados
serán acusados ante los tribunales por
los delitos de homicidio culposo
lesiones culposas y estragos públicos de
acuerdo con el Ministerio Público las
puertas habilitadas no eran suficientes
para el número de aficionados Además de
que dichos accesos no fueron abiertos
con suficiente anticipación para el
ingreso ordenado Y seguro asistentes
también la sobreventa fue una de las
primeras hipótesis de las autoridades de
seguridad para explicar las causas de la
tragedia al respecto a la fiscalía
señaló que los organizadores al agotar
las entradas disponibles para el
encuentro deportivo decidieron
comercializar ilegalmente boletos
emitidos para encuentros anteriores los
acusados serán presentados ante un
tribunal en los próximos días y deberán
responder de manera individual ya sea
por sus acciones u omisiones tal como lo
expresó el fiscal general Al momento de
iniciar Las investigaciones del caso
este miércoles 24 las autoridades
deportivas confirmaron que el torneo
clausura 2023 de la primera división no
continuará debido a la falta de
garantías y de plan de seguridad para la
fase final del certamen